PEGAH HAGHIGHAT:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
I'm excited for today.
We're going to have a special
performance by PJ Morton.
Please give around of
applause for PJ Morton.
[APPLAUSE]
[PLAYING PIANO]
PJ MORTON: Happy to be
here to hang with you guys.
I don't get to play
to offices that much.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm going to sing a
couple of songs for you--
[PLAYING PIANO]
--from my album "Gumbo"
that we put out this year.
[PLAYING PIANO]
And so the first one goes--
[PJ MORTON SINGING "FIRST
BEGAN"]
You got to help me
snap right here.
[PJ MORTON SINGING "FIRST
BEGAN"]
That's it, yeah.
[PJ MORTON SINGING "FIRST
BEGAN"]
Keep snapping, yeah.
[PJ MORTON SINGING "FIRST
BEGAN"]
Thank you all so much.
[APPLAUSE]
You all are some
amazing snappers.
I just got to give you
props for your snap.
This next song right here is--
when I was making
this album, it was
after having a bunch of meetings
and trying to figure out what
I wanted to do as an artist.
I feel like I got lost and
things got cluttered for me.
Some of you may not know, but
I'm also in the band Maroon 5.
So seeing all their success
and being a part of something
so huge somewhat confused me
of who I was as a solo artist
and what I wanted to say.
And I decided to leave LA,
move back home to New Orleans,
and really get back
down to the basis of who
I felt I was and got back
to the reason I made music
in the first place, which
is, at the foundation,
just to do something special and
make some art that is special.
I want to sell records.
I want to do all
those good things.
But at the basis of it, I
want to be making something
that I want to make.
This one's called
Claustrophobic.
You don't have to snap on this.
[PLAYING PIANO]
[PJ MORTON SINGING
"CLAUSTROPHOBIC"]
All right, thank y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Thank you.
Hi, PJ.
Thanks for being here at
Google in San Francisco.
PJ MORTON: Glad to be here.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Very
excited to have you here.
So I know today you're here.
Also, you're touring
with Maroon 5 currently.
You're going to perform tonight
in Oakland at the Oracle Arena.
First, I want to
start off and ask you,
how did you start with music?
And how did it feel to get
into this whole business
at the very beginning?
PJ MORTON: Right, well,
I started in music--
being from New Orleans,
obviously, it's
a big part of the
makeup of the city.
And I had a musical family.
My father was a singer
and a preacher-- a pastor.
So I grew up in church
playing as a preacher's kid,
and got into the business very
early because the musicians
that my father had around
were also songwriters and had
played songs.
So I got my first placement--
I was introduced to
the business at 15
and got a song on an album,
and it kind of went from there.
I moved to Atlanta, went to
Morehouse, and met Andy Irie.
And that was my first major
placement on an album.
And that won a Grammy award
while I was a junior in college
still.
At that point, it
was just all exciting
because that was my dream.
Even leaving New
Orleans was in an effort
to get in the business
because New Orleans,
and why I'm back
in New Orleans, is
to help build that
music infrastructure
because while there is music and
entertainment infrastructure,
the best musicians in
the world are there.
There has never been a real
business there for music.
It's why I had to leave
and find the business.
And now I'm back
to combine the two.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: OK, great.
Great.
I also know you toured
with Erykah Badu.
PJ MORTON: Yeah.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: She's amazing.
So how was that?
PJ MORTON: Amazing.
Yeah, that was my
very first tour.
First time on a tour bus.
My first time in
church on a Sunday.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't know what
to do on a Sunday.
I was like, wait,
do we go to church?
I was a true preacher's kid.
Erykah is such an amazing--
I was just lucky to have my
start be with someone who is
such an artist, such a leader.
Like a culture shifter.
So that is amazing.
And we still stay in
contact now these days.
She's always been
a huge supporter
of whatever I was doing.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: OK.
And then after you
were touring with her,
you started to get into
the band with Maroon 5.
So how is that?
How is that getting
into a group like that,
and also starting your solo
career here on the side?
PJ MORTON: Yeah, well, I had
the longest writer's block
I ever had while I
was out with Erykah.
I tell songwriters to
live first and then write.
So I was trying to
write while I was taking
on all these new
experiences, and couldn't
write a song at all.
And when I got off the road with
Erykah, I wrote my first album.
It was like two songs a day.
Everything came out
that I experienced.
And then there was some
songwriting, and some albums,
and some touring
in between there.
And I had a friend,
Adam Blackstone,
who's like the music
director to the stars.
And he would always
ask me to be on gigs
to play keys because I was
a keyboard player first
before an artist.
And I would always turn it
down because I was trying
to focus on being an artist.
But when he called about
the Maroon 5 thing,
I was like, well,
this is different.
And I was also at a point
where I was had a plateau
with what I was doing.
And it was my first
audition ever.
I had never auditioned
for anything.
And it was their first.
Maroon's been a band
since eighth grade.
So it was awkward
for both of us.
They're like, what
are we supposed to do?
I'm like, I don't know.
I've never--
So they asked me to
learn Sunday Morning.
And I flew to LA, and
played it, and then we
ended up just jamming
for like half an hour.
And there were other
people waiting to audition.
So they said they knew.
And I kind of felt it too.
I guess it speaks
to a lot of things,
because there are a lot
of amazing musicians
that could have probably done
that, but we vibed as people
and connected as people.
And they canceled the
second day of auditions.
And it's been eight
years now next month
that I've been with the band.
It's been a crazy ride.
This was before "The Voice".
This was before
Moves Like Jagger.
We call it pre and
post Moves Like Jagger.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: How do you
feel about doing your solo thing
and also the Maroon 5 both
at the same time basically?
PJ MORTON: I just feel tired.
It is a great problem to have.
I just got off of a solo tour
and had a week in between
and started this Maroon 5
tour a couple of days ago.
It's amazing, man.
Like I said, it's just
good problems to have.
The guys are very
supportive of me.
I've done double duty on
tour where I open the tour
and then close as Maroon 5.
I've done that
here and in Europe.
And they don't have to do that.
I don't even expect that.
But that just speaks to the
type of people they are.
It's challenging schedule wise
and not having any downtime,
but YOLO.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: So you
also recorded a song
with Stevie Wonder,
which is pretty great.
PJ MORTON: It's all right.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: How
was it to meet him
and to make music with him?
And who would you like to
work with in the future?
Are there any artists
you really want
to work with as a solo artist?
PJ MORTON: Yeah, so to put it
in perspective, as a keyboard
player who wrote
songs and sang, Stevie
was just my ultimate--
is my ultimate right now.
And when people would ask me
that question on interviews,
who do you want to collab with?
And it was always Stevie.
So after I worked with Stevie,
I was kind of like, ruined it--
that question.
I had to think differently.
He's my hero.
Some people ask me if I'm--
because things are
reminiscent of Stevie.
And of course, I'm
sitting down playing.
It offends me that people
say I'm so much like--
look like Stevie or
trying to sound like him.
But I'm honored by that.
It's like, he knows that
I'm not trying to imitate.
I just been heavily influenced.
And to have him there makes
me not care about any of that
because he supports.
And still, Stevie wants to
work on new music with me
and stuff like that.
It really is surreal, and
I feel like I'm in a dream.
I've listened to the song
that I collaborated with him
on probably 100,000
times, and I'm
still shocked every
time I hear that Stevie
is on a song with me.
Yeah, it really is a dream
come true, like literally.
As far as people I'd
like to work with,
I think of more current
people now because that
was like the big hero from--
but like a Kendrick Lamar.
Pulitzer Prize winner, Kendrick.
Yeah, like Chance the Rapper.
I want to produce
something with Pharrell.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: So
speaking of that,
you were nominated for two
Grammys for your current album,
"Gumbo".
So how do you feel about that?
And also, what made
you create this album?
And where does the
name come from?
Can you tell a
little about that?
PJ MORTON: Yeah, well, it
was me moving back home
in New Orleans.
I was an artist after I
moved away from New Orleans,
so I never made
a record at home.
So that was part of it,
just a nod to gumbo.
But really, on a deeper level,
I wanted to challenge myself.
I've written a
lot of love songs.
I wanted to challenge myself to
talk about more than just love
this time around.
I felt like the world was
just a little too crazy
to only focus on that.
I wanted to address things
that I was feeling as a person,
like Claustrophobic.
There's some on there
called religion.
Just deal with different
things other than love.
Of course, there's First Began
and other love songs on there.
But for me, it started
to feel like all
this different subject matter.
And gumbo is a dish where you
put all these different things
in there to make this
one beautiful thing.
And I feel like
that's what I did.
And I made it in New Orleans, so
that's why I named it "Gumbo".
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Great, great.
And you started your own
label, Morton Records.
So how did you find
the time to do that
in between all this craziness?
And how do you how do
you feel about that?
PJ MORTON: I just
think I'm insane.
It's not a great idea to
start a music label right now
in the world.
This speaks to my passion.
We're calling it the
Motown of New Orleans
because I'm really trying
to focus on local talent
the way Motown did, and really
develop some of the things
that I care about.
I am a firm believer
in not complaining
about what's out there
or what you don't like,
but actually doing
something about it.
So this is my way of
balancing music and trying
to put some things out there
that I feel need to be heard.
And it's been awesome so far.
We're going very slow because I
don't want to take on too much
and not really be able
to put attention to it.
But it's been awesome.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Great, great.
And what would you recommend
for people who are out there,
like young artists,
musicians, who
want to get into the
business but really don't
know how to put their
first foot into the door?
What would you tell them?
PJ MORTON: It's much
easier than when I started.
There's way more access.
The playing field is way more
equal than it used to be.
I feel like writers
write, artists make art,
so I would just say
start where you are
and use the tools that
you have right there.
I couldn't use a
laptop initially
to make music when I was first
starting out at 14 or 15.
So you have things right there.
You have your phone even
where you can start.
I would say start to
create immediately and find
your people.
I think what I love about the
internet is that you can find
your people, whoever they are.
It's ways that they
can get to you.
But you've got to start with
the lowest hanging fruit.
Just start with
who's around you.
Start with your friends,
start with your city,
and then just continue
to grow it that way.
There's that old
grass roots thing.
You can just put steroids
on it with the internet.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: OK, great.
Thanks, PJ.
So we're ready for some Q&A. So
if you guys have any questions,
there is a mic.
Please line up and
free to ask away.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Hey, man.
AUDIENCE: How's it going?
PJ MORTON: Anticipation
from the walking.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was like, I'm
really the only one up here.
No, thank you for those opening
songs, for sharing some words.
I'm just curious since
it's pretty much all you--
you are producing the lyrics,
producing the sounds, which
tends to come first for you?
Are you a person who
sits with your notebook,
and writes these lyrics,
and then jams after?
Or do you feel it in your hands?
PJ MORTON: It's usually
musical for me first.
I think maybe only
two times in my life
have I written
down lyrics first.
I'll always have song
title ideas, or a line,
and I'll put that in my phone
and maybe come back to it.
But it's always
melodic first for me,
and then I put words to it.
Paul McCartney talks
about writing Yesterday.
And he had a dream and it was
scrambled eggs, da da da--
this is like my process.
It's really close my process.
It's like nothing first, and
then I put words to it after.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PJ MORTON: Yeah, man.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
PJ MORTON: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here.
I have a quick question
for those of us
who are not in bands
but do understand what
it's like working with a team.
What was the conversation when
you had to talk to the band
about wanting to do solo work?
Was that difficult?
Is that a challenging thing?
You've been with Maroon
5 for a long time.
I'm sure you're like a family.
PJ MORTON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was that hard,
or were they OK with it?
PJ MORTON: Well, the
easy thing about it
was when I joined the band, they
knew I was an artist already.
So I kind of came
in as an artist.
What was maybe more challenging
was when I decided to leave LA.
Because I moved to LA
because of the band,
to be closer to
everybody, and I wasn't
going to leave LA if they
weren't totally cool with it
as a group.
It was important to me.
And they realized that
it's different now.
When I first joined the band, we
could call surprise rehearsals,
there was no "Voice" schedule,
no TV, all that stuff.
So things could just pop up.
Thankfully, our schedule was
locked in for a long time
ahead, so they
understood my reasoning
and knew that I would not be
any less dedicated from where
I was.
Yeah, we're doing all right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
PJ MORTON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So as
a woman of color,
I think as you continue
to advance yourself,
you get degrees, you
get the great jobs,
you start to think
about how do you
use your platform
to raise awareness
for different
issues of injustice.
And so I'm curious to know how
you think about now that you
started your own label,
you're establishing
your own career
separate from Maroon 5,
how do you think
about leveraging
your platform as a musician to
speak to all the issues that
are affecting people today?
PJ MORTON: I think as
an artist, we've always
been the way to soften the
blows of a conversation,
making it musical and
making people sing along.
And I, in the spirit of Marvin,
and Stevie, and those guys,
always feel necessary.
I think that's
what I was alluding
to when I was saying
that I couldn't just
talk about love this time.
There's songs like
Everything's Going
To Be All Right and All Right on
my album that deal with what's
going on and how
divisive it is right now.
And that's the best
way I know how.
That's my tool.
That's the strongest
tool I have is music.
So I use that the most.
I feel like that's thing that
comes to be the most natural.
But then I also lend
my voice to people
who can't be as loud as I can.
It's important to me.
Very.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
I was wondering if
you could comment
about the role of formal music
training in your own past,
and how that has or hasn't
been part of your development.
And also if you could
talk about the musicians
that you played with, if
you've noticed differences
between those who have and
haven't really formally studied
music versus learning from
being in bands, and friends,
and so on.
PJ MORTON: Sure.
Well, my experience
is kind of unpopular.
My mom really wanted me
to take piano lessons
and become a classical musician.
I quit piano lessons
probably after two weeks
because I was playing
stuff on the radio
and playing stuff on TV.
And I had a gift.
So to go from playing What's
Happening Now to da da da da--
I was like, nah,
I can't do this.
So I didn't really
have the discipline.
But I also feel
like with anything--
I went to Morehouse.
Marketing was what
I got my degree in.
And I felt like I was a
natural marketer already.
I think with anything you do
in life, we have purposes in us
already that we use formal
training and other things
to perfect.
So I think, especially
being from New Orleans,
these musicians--
there was no notation,
there was no reading music.
The music came first.
And somebody said,
well, let's figure out
a way to put this on paper to
allow other people to do it.
But I think some of the
elitists in music got it twisted
and looked down on people
who can't read music.
But those are the people
who have the gift already,
and they can use reading
and school to perfect that.
But it was already in
me, so I personally
didn't want to learn music.
My training came from
experience being on the road,
being on 16 passenger
vans, going from city
to city and touching
people, and being on stage.
I think that's one
thing we're missing.
One thing my focus is at
Morton Records is development,
because it's missing
because we have YouTube
and somebody can get a million
views, and then they go
and they're a star, and they
missed a whole bunch of steps.
And that's why we see some
people who can't perform live.
And I think that's
where the longevity is.
So that was my training.
My training was having the vets
around me and watching them.
I didn't necessarily
have the formal training
of being a musician.
I said if Stevie can't read
music, I'll be all right.
[LAUGHTER]
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: OK,
one more last question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, PJ.
PJ MORTON: Hey, man.
AUDIENCE: This is awesome.
Thank you.
I have a songwriting question.
So you touched on,
as a solo artist,
you do want to sell records.
But at the same time,
you want to really make
music that's true to
the root of who you are.
And so my question is when
you're creating music,
how do you think about the
compromise between expressing
what you want to express,
but also making that music
accessible to a lot of people?
And do you even see
that as a compromise?
PJ MORTON: So the thing
about me as a songwriter
is I've always loved pop
music in the sense of when
I say pop music, I mean songs
that people can sing along to.
It's never been my
taste to be so left
that it's like you've got to
be super deep to understand it.
That's never been my
thing, so I didn't ever
have a challenge with
writing a chorus that people
could sing along to.
So I don't see that
as a compromise.
Aside from that, I don't really
get deep into-- or I try not
to--
get deep into being
strategic about how
this song should be to
make it on the radio
or something like that.
That's what I had to
get away from, because I
did have that for a long time.
All I wanted to do was be
jamming for my friends.
That's as far as it goes now.
Because when I was a
kid being a musician,
when I learn something, I
want to impress my friends.
So I think of the world
as if my friends like it,
I don't care who else likes it.
So that's my
compromise these days.
It's like, make the
coolest thing you think,
and then just trust that.
As opposed to what's popping
on the radio right now?
Let me see if I can do
something like that.
Because, especially
now, trends move
so fast that you're
late once you
make a Cardi B sounding record.
It's over, you know
what I'm saying?
That sound has been
done a million times.
So I find that it's so hard
to get through the clutter
these days.
That's the gift and
the curse of things
being more accessible now.
Anybody can be out there.
So there's a lot of clutter.
And I think the way you
get through the clutter
these days is honest music.
People want to be connected,
feel connected to something.
Even Cardi.
I'm not talking about sonically,
but the reason she cut through
is because she was a real
person and she didn't try
to be something else to sell.
So I think being honest is as
much as the compromise goes,
and just trying to
impress my people.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Thank you.
OK, so I think we have
one more song coming up
before we're done.
PJ MORTON: All right,
I'll play another song.
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT: Yes, please.
[APPLAUSE]
[PLAYING PIANO]
PJ MORTON: All right,
so if you know this one,
I want you all to help me.
I did a cover on this album.
I looked up the top
10 songs of all time
and one of my favorites
just happened to be there.
It's How Deep Is Your
Love by the Bee Gees.
Are they from Austrailia?
Yeah, I think.
Aussies, they had
some soul in there.
I felt the soul in there.
But I'm like, I think I can
fully put the soul in it.
So I redid it, and I'm going
to do that one right now.
[PLAYING PIANO]
[PJ MORTON SINGING "HOW DEEP IS
YOUR LOVE"]
Thank you all so much, man.
[APPLAUSE]
PEGAH HAGHIGHAT:
Thank you so much, PJ.